okay so let's get this out of the way at
first
oh that's just okay when I saw the time
and where as the story starts is still
the ice King's fan story and it is
hilarious always change directions heads
while that's crazy
we she tracked her prints hilarious ah
and then Marceline comes in which it's
nice to see you know it's nice to see
her coming about them ya know it was so
funny I was just like what's going on
the Vice king of Marceline
BAM they're in the next episode and I
love the idea she's like I want to let
someone else tell the story I think
that's a great idea uh you know and I
like that he's reading it to all the
princesses you know in cage then she
lets him go but they still wanna listen
to the story you know so she starts
telling the story and it's about her
male counterpart Marshall Lee with
that's all where his name uh and just
about there quasi kind of relationship
and then just sort of hanging out
together and and at the end he's like
you know he's he's making a little he's
gonna die by the Sun and he's like you
know admit it you love me did you Yvonne
my tenth that you love me and she pretty
much said no right she's like no I don't
and you're crazy it's like well you're
the most real person I know hey this is
all fake and everything you know can we
hang out oh my cheek meat and you know
ice creams like oh that's crap you get
out do you know you don't like my thorry
and he goes down and he just has like a
frickin shrine made out of I think it
was I said yeah I made out of ice thank
you to me it's like one day it will be
real I don't know how but I'll make you
real and it's like what about the
mountains and mountains of volumes of
stories yeah and lousy I'm volume five
here in the other
saga yes so on the one hand that makes
me say oh good there's a lot more oh
yeah because I don't know what it is
there is something about parallel
dimension well this is what the reasons
of shock infinity I love parallel
dimensions where it's like you just see
these little differences and even
something as little it's like just
switching the genders around or species
in the case of Jake you know you just
sort of go like okay what would this
look like or what would this be like
what you just I want to see everything
and that that's what the reasons I like
the first one so much because I got to
feel these showed so much of the well
I'm keeping the humor is so good and and
with this one it's mostly like a
relationship between Fiona and Marshall
Lee and it's like for episode two I mean
I'm just like okay okay in the party for
you see which is some good stuff I love
seeing lumpy Space Prince with a the
voice doesn't change at all
BMO's pretty much the same you know like
that cast up is we're trying to treat
chunks with this I just loved the visor
yeah distinction yeah and then the pig
just has a bow so yeah like I love
seeing all this I wanted more of that Oh
with the boobs yeah oh I missed that one
the worms
so it's totally fine don't get me wrong
but it's other things with Brett I know
you know cuz they know cuz the opening
stir it all so good I think that argue
the ending was like I mean how about you
just watching you're like yeah I'm just
like that's quite disturbing um the only
ER thing I find very interesting it's
because Marceline is telling the story
where the male her you know has a
relationship with you know the female
Fiona it's kind of like huh like I don't
know what to read it to that exactly you
know letting out her emotions towards
Finn
through this storytelling or is it just
to make a good story yeah that bets are
one of wonder because even in the story
they don't quite you know if they don't
get together I mean they're still
friends we're but they're like it's kind
of open-ended like you know is there
anything there that's a Z or maybe it'll
grow or whatever um so uh I thought was
I thought was fun I mean like for an
episode two I'd be like oh let's I like
they do something a little different
it's not just a great big adventure I
guess um but I guess I respect that's
like okay just like a more relationship
story but it's like I don't know for the
second one like I was loving the opening
with the third the dolphin is like next
time book it's a bomb I mean I can quote
so much from just that opening few
seconds Ice King is the best yeah a nice
kid coming out of the box I mean I can
quote so much from that first couple of
seconds and the rest of it with the
exception of cheek meat you know it's
like I have a hard time remembering so I
decided it's but I just you've got so
many volumes I'd love to see more I'd
love to see different characters
actually tell the story if that's the
route they're going I'd love to see like
we had Marceline do one that I'd love to
see like I don't know tree trunks or
Jake or a bin or somebody else come in
and tell and tell their version of the
Fionna cake story I think that'd be
great at the time tree trunks is done
telling her story great cheap box it'll
be a 20-minute episode ever just mr.
tree terms of hilarious
so so that's what I got Jason with all
your reactions over there you know you
got to go next
uh no I I thought it was a fine episode
it was did everything fine I like that
you know as little of a part that Neil
Patrick like Harris had in this one he
still came back to do it I like that
everyone came back to redo those roles
like it's nice to to see these people
enjoy doing the show well enough that
they're willing to come back I did love
the whole throwing this the knife around
cutting his hair he's like oh you almost
wolves it cut my dome-piece
yeah uh then it's starting what's up
there oh it's raining and he's like oh
I'm not going up there it's raining I
did like that little bubble gum and
Marceline
Marcia Lee gumball still kind of needing
to bow down before the other in a sense
I really liked that which again to me
again is Marceline
putting her feelings into this
storytelling or is it just well this is
the natural progression of how things
would have happened um I don't know I
just I think that she's probably putting
a little bit of her emotions into it um
I did love them when they were singing
for fourteen-year-old girl she looks
really good remember when she called
okay when she pulls up the top and her
hair came down oh you're talking about
being in front of the mirror going
oh yeah that's sexy no I'm saying ghost
that was creepy too I like to point out
no like when Finn first took off his
hood and he's like as a glowing hearing
he's like wow the glowing eyes that's
kind of how this was and it was very
nicely done it fell down and it was very
pretty looking I was it likes it that
way for a reason
I will say the long hair death around
her Oh what's wrong with that
you know like us long hair no I just
that looks better on her actually
something I noticed about this one I
think this might be the very first
episode where there is literally no Finn
and Jake I mean at all
you got Fionna and cake but even in the
original Fionna and cake they show up at
the end this is none no we had one more
before the Cynthia remember it well the
Friendship is Magic one that's right
that weird episode yeah twiggles Branca
yeah so we are then never tied into the
condo oh man okay so maybe well maybe
maybe no I liked it it was fun I like I
said when when her hat came off
it was very beautifully drawn that's why
I was I was making the joke and I got
the appropriate reaction now what I
found interesting was when they're
messing around while cake is dancing and
singing uh you know she tries to trip
him and then elbows him and then she
keep he kicks her straight in the face
and I know there's people out there that
have like issue with violence towards
girls in like something like this and
it's one of those for me it's like well
I don't consider that straight-up
violence it's just kind of like they
were messing around because that's kind
of what they do because right after that
cake runs over and he knocks her out of
the way boys yeah well no marks Marshall
Marshall Diego told me that's a little
bit more aggressive you know what if you
notice when they're running away
she's a few doughnuts holding cake and
he's like oh come on I was only messing
around look at Kate's face she smiles
opens up one I was like hey Kelly I
totally got you sucker yeah I mean to me
it's very much like you know like anyway
it's punch punch punch
I mean seemed very much like you know
roughhousing and you know and there they
were the heroes they're gonna go in like
they they put their lives on the line
and fight things and stuff so it's like
they're probably used to you know a few
yeah lunch is here and they ever finish
a human callus so so I liked the episode
I liked it I liked it it's so good you
know it's just like for an episode I
just answered that bit of episode three
but again I'm going to sell I've gotten
way too selfish I mean like I'm just
like whatever this stuff is going at him
just like we got a spec it's like I
don't know I'm very selfish that way
talk about Marshall Lee cuz you're gonna
lose voice David Glover no clover
fantastic childish can be no I don't
know how I don't it is it just the
voices at the character to that I feel
like marshalese character here is kind
of earth it reminds me a lot more of
when Marceline first kind of came on to
the show and doing kind of the same
things that Marcy was doing right at the
beginning so I didn't have a problem
with it I thought it was kind of neat
kind of cool I think he's more or less
as in is it the bad-boy image that helps
it out just in general or just once
I mean just the voice I just have a
thing for voices you're full of it boys
well I was gonna say cuz if it's a like
you you guys were talking I mean I'm
guessing is Marshall Lee sort of like a
big fan crush among like girls and stuff
or not really I guess to know it depends
yeah yeah
the con we were at there was a fair
number of both marshalese and
Marceline's I think both of them are a
fan favorite overall so I mean no Joey
you have a thing for bad boys you know
most women have a thing for bad boys to
be fameless
I was gonna say that's not bad boys
that's flower no no no see the thing you
have to understand what kdramas is the
main lead the main male are in the wrong
v-log Sarris assholes no they treat the
women like complete nutter garbage and
when i mean like literally leaving them
out in the rain telling them they're
ugly such as like pow exactly
so they are like bad boys and Joey likes
them so I had a bad way it just sounds
like a dick this one this one pretends
he doesn't like them but he does you
know what I want to go the dungeon crawl
I will say I'll say one last thing by
the way we have a friend you've seen him
it - Polly flee another Jim trogon
whenever I see it because he was
Marshall Lee for Halloween once and
that's all I see when I watch this I'm
just like well there's Jim it's like no
difference I'm just like I'm looking at
Jim joking right now so yeah he was
breakin to bully flee and he was the
stone and you don't think is every night
so he's been a few things and yeah it's
probably you like the guy see a few
Marshall leads to and that's like the
best Marshall leave we one friend Rick
with a W and he does a really good I
know it's anyway he does a really really
excellent I love you slow bro get back
here dungeon cop he's pretty great and
also yeah so I guess we have to close up
the episode why don't you be me you be
the female me I'll be male you girls